[Music]
[Music]
wrapped up in my lovers
[Music]
[Music]
scratch the surface
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why'd you kill the music i think you
know why um
i don't think i do
begins with an l
like the l word
lesbians
lost max we're lost we're just we're in
geographic flux right so
lost
that's debatable
yeah honey nice catch
thank you
man the roads are definitely getting
worse out here i guess it's all part of
the rustic summer camp experience oh
right that's where we're going i lost
track like 200 miles ago 200 miles ago
huh
you know what max is okay it doesn't
make you any less of a man you know if
columbus hadn't gotten lost and landed
on these golden shores there would be no
united states of america
goodbye hot dogs see you later apple pie
columbus never actually landed in north
america
what are you talking about
didn't even know he wasn't in asia are
you serious
just another guy who didn't want to
admit he was lost well just another guy
who's got a whole day named after him so
put that in your pipe and smoke it oh my
god okay just get us to camp already
before i roll my eyes out of my head
please i'm working on it i'm working on
it
ah voila
what is that
yeah yeah no but seriously what happened
to the the normal map this is the normal
map the one on the phone
no bars
of course not
okay let's see so we are
well i guess they don't put summer camps
on maps
have you seen any signs for it
hey eyes on the road
max
[Music]
are you okay
yeah yeah
i mean
still in one piece jesus christ what do
you think that was a bear
what
no no max i wasn't a bear what was it
i think it was a person
lord are you serious
do you think we hit a person
i don't know
i mean it was really close like really
close but maybe we didn't
what is it
i really have this car up
well maybe it looks worse than it is
uh
i should check out the damage before we
try to start it up again huh could you
grab my uh the toolbox from the trunk
yeah yeah okay
max
why didn't you tell me
thanks hon
yeah
do you need a hand yeah actually if you
could just shine a light right here
there you go perfect thank you
the sooner we get out of here the better
just picture yourself curling up in
front of a big old fire pit singing
campfire sing-alongs i don't think
people curl up right in front of big old
fire pits why not
uh they don't want to catch on fire then
picture yourself pulling up in front of
a big old spacing
well anywhere's better than here
where you going
just over here just
stay there for a second okay i'm almost
done
what you're not the boss of me i just
don't want you wandering off on your own
excuse me that's not what i meant
yeah it better not be i i'm sorry i
really got to concentrate for a second
okay yes
look i think there's someone down there
okay what's that
they could be heart
i'm gonna go check it out
[Music]
good idea laura so thoughtful of you
froze
um
[Music]
so
what the hell
silas
dog boy
[Music]
yikes
this is too weird
silas
side
[Music]
where are you
silence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
max
max hey hey why are you shouting
oh my god
what
what the hell was that
car
now
did you see it no but i heard something
let's just get out of here
come on
oh god i thought you said you checked it
i did check it and it was fine
honey i know you're on edge but you
gotta calm down okay i'm not on edge max
i'm freaking the [ __ ] out probably just
an animal or no it wasn't an animal you
didn't see it it was a woman this isn't
helping all right go there we go we're
good see please just get us out of here
max i'm trying i'm trying
we're okay we're safe in the car really
we're gonna be okay chase oh [ __ ]
oh my god my heart just exploded
roll it down
hi officer how are you doing this
evening are either of you injured no uh
what she bumped her head well barely
barely bumped in i mean i can i can't
even feel it my bum not my head i'm fine
really we're fine we're just a little
shaken up
well you folks want to tell me what
happened here
we um
something jumped out right in front of
the car and we didn't want to hit it so
we swerved and
now here we are
something jumped out
uh
an animal
you know yeah um it's just
don't know what kind it was so fast and
yeah
well it was most likely a deer
sir
keep the car running
sir
is this kind like the all-time scariest
kind
i don't know this is my first cop what
like ever
uh yeah i'm not a criminal
[Applause]
now you folks want to tell me
just what in the hell
you are doing all the way out here this
late at night
we're heading up to hackett's core
summer camp
we're new counselors
you're one night early no no we know um
but we figured we'd get in early and
scope it out you know i mean they know
we're coming we called ahead
and to be honest sir one of us kind of
oversold their navigation skills and got
us completely lost
you're not gonna make it to heck it's
quarry
not tonight
harbinger motel it's the nearest place
you can bunk up there for the night okay
uh
i think we're just gonna stick to the
plan sir i mean mr hackett knows we're
coming and be called ahead no ma'am
you're gonna head to the harbinger motel
do you understand
with all due respect sir why can't we go
to hack it's quarry because i told you
to go to the motel
okay i just don't understand what the
problem i am please step out of the
vehicle
officer she didn't do anything
ma'am
if you wouldn't mind stepping out of the
vehicle i would just like to show you a
route on your map there
okay
for sure
son
remain in the vehicle
okay
okay
so
we
are right about here
harbinger motel
is here
right okay and where was hackett's corey
again
well
i'm sure the fine folks
at the harbinger motel can guide you
there
first thing in the morning
[Music]
still please
what are you doing
[Music]
hold
still
excuse me
ma'am
i can take care of myself you okay yeah
i'm fine
you can return to your vehicle now man
harbinger motel
stay on the road
watch out for potholes
oh you need like a good night
why is this guy just sitting there
that guy was giving me major weirdos
they do needed like at least a dozen
showers oh my god i know what was up
with the thing
was what is it blood
nice to
meet you
oh man
all right let's get back on the road yes
i think i've had enough woodland
encounters for one night thank you very
much i agree so where's this motel okay
so we're here and the motel is here okay
but we're going here what's there
heck it's corey
how'd you do that
i don't know kind of tricked him into
showing
very slick
are you sure we shouldn't just get to
the motel just listen to this guy's
advice
honey you really want to listen to the
advice of some creep ass cop who told us
in the middle of the creep ass woods to
go to some creep ass hotel
no that sounds terrible let's hit the
road shall we that's what i thought
ma'am
oh my god if he called me ma'am one more
time i was gonna shove that badge up his
dick
seriously do i look like a man to you
i got like 20 years before i'm a man
what
20 is
debatable easy i mean i'm kind of into
mams
okay we're done
you gotta be kidding me there's nobody
here we drive all the way the [ __ ] out
here can we just look around before we
jump to the conclusion did you actually
even talk to mr hackett or did you just
leave a message what's the difference
this this is the difference
hello
i guess he doesn't check his voicemail
how was i supposed to know that
i mean clearly there's somebody here
yeah or it's just an abandoned car and
this is a complete race why would there
be an abandon
i'll get the car
next come on
max don't be a dick i'm sorry
i'm sorry
fun
what doesn't kill you will make you
stronger
hey
hey are you okay
[Music]
i'll be right back i'm gonna get some
help
max
max get over here what's going on
there's somebody in the bunker i think
they might be stuck
stuck
is it mr hackett i i don't know just
bring some tools so we can break the law
hey i'm back
we're gonna get you out of there
hey hey
wait what are these i don't know you
just said tools
why didn't you just bring
look there's someone in there
um
i'm not seeing anyone no look i'm
looking i am
there there was definitely someone there
okay okay so
you sure
yeah i saw it online
damn
you need a hand yeah
you've seen the evil death
hello
are you hurt do you exist
hey
be careful
max
so
hon maybe it was a possum or something
no there was there was someone here i
swear
hey
it's been kind of a night you know
let's just get to the motel we can come
back here first thing in the morning we
can check everything out but
i mean you must be exhausted i know i am
i think our
imagination max
max
max
yes what
help
okay
[Music]
now
does this look like the goddamn
harbinger motel to you
every little movement
every little thing you do
is
[Music]
i feel the compassion
this miracle
[Music]
is beyond improvements
you are the magician
i've been wishing for
forever
you